hi sama thanks for coming to talk to us
at Glamour today thank you
we're here today to talk about a very
serious subject and one that we know is
close to your heart
the White Ribbon For Women campaign
could you just tell us a bit more about
it the white ribbon campaign it's been
launched by the caring foundation our
main cause is to stop violence against
women to create awareness now through
social media there is a great channel of
communication for victims of violence to
talk to each other and last year was
over 300 million people participated
through social media and the campaign
women often feel ashamed or to blame if
they're victims of domestic abuse which
prevents them from speaking out how
important is a is it for us to bust this
to both it is very important that we
continue to talk about it
that it is not okay I think this will
gave the courage to man to stop the
cycle as well as to women to get out of
it as a well-known person in Hollywood
she must get approached all the time by
charities and campaigns why why is why
this one why is this the one that's
close to your heart I've been an
activist against violence against women
for over 20 years it's a problem that
really affects society in many ways it's
not just that the women are the victim
we are all the victims many of our
social problems start right there we
were saying earlier that you know sort
of women's issues which obviously know
people issues Emma Watson Jennifer Owens
it seems to be sort of quite something
that people are talking about though
lots more
especially in the media why do you think
this sort of sudden change now because I
think of the amount of work that's been
done and people not giving up on it and
repeating and repeating it to the point
where like I was saying it just begins
to dawn on people you've been with the
caring foundation since 2009 what have
you learned in that time obviously
you've run a lot but what are the sort
of key things if somebody wants to take
a leave
to go so fieldwork in some of these
countries the company supports this
initiative so the people that work there
are constantly being aware of what's
happening and invited to participate in
an effort to make a better world for
women because this is the main goal of
caring through the caring foundation so
Stella McCartney one of the board
members has designed this gorgeous
brooch that you're wearing and I'm
wearing for the elimination of violence
against women day on the 25th of
November how important is it and how can
we all get involved I think now what
it's different now than before is social
media
we participate in trying to create a
community of women that support our
placement in the world I think you're an
inspiration and I'm sure your children
look up to you in a big way so who do
you draw inspiration from in your own
life I draw my inspiration from the
women that I've met that nobody knows
that have endure unimaginable things
they are so courageous and our true
heroes thank you so much for coming to
see us today and we wish you all the
luck with the campaign and we'll be all
wearing our badges and tweeting and
using a hashtags and everything's yeah
thank you